welcome to this video this is coverage
for day two of the road rapid
championships in Dubai and yeah the
leader after round no after on ten yes
and today to with some not very
surprisingly actually magnus carlsen
whole world champion he am pretty much
you had a very good day on this day two
he had started with four out of five and
day one and repeated the same score
winning three games drawing two very
solid performance as usual he never
really got into much trouble and turn
was pressing in most games and yeah
bringing important ones so it's leading
the tournament i'll look at two games
from from Magnus and then switch to some
other games and also show who some yeah
hottest the hottest contender to chase
cards and on the third day let's start
here carlton against on mosey on over to
be honest i'd made a mistake him need to
load this again just a moment okay load
it on cards Movsisyan llamastes l is
very strong GM also it's been around
2,700 for four years and years playing
for Armenia now played for the Czech
Republic for a while okay we don't want
to do this game um yeah completely each
move I want to focus on the position
check let me get somewhat somewhat lay
down we have a Queens gambit Rogozin
very popular opening nowadays giving
blacker quite good results and around
here we see a typical transformation
with d5 white is gaining some space here
with d 45 just before black is able to
play a 5 himself or play d5 bishop
two on yeah to get them rooks to the C
file yeah black here does not have much
choice he needs to retreat the night
queen before yeah yeah there was b5 now
threatened and now he five yeah what
about this position is this is this
equal or is this an something for for
one side yeah if we look at what happens
here we see that white has slightly more
active pieces the Queen on b3 is a nice
asset in term this also know 15 tonight
possibly joining on c4 especially the
night c4 to be six c4 to a five this can
be slightly tricky for black there is
also this Bishop on on f5 which is quite
an interesting piece if we look at what
happens we have this Chinese trades
which is logical the C file is open
enter we will have those trades there we
look at this now after you form we see
that this night on CA it is blocking the
retreat square c eight black pretty much
would like to stay on this diagonal
sorry i'm not sure why this keeps
popping up um wants to stay on this
diagonal sg6 this is how he must react
now bishop c6 a g6 is the only move
really and as Bishop d7 is hanging b7
cannot do that and this is a slightly
uncomfortable thing for black yeah you
would like to have the bishop helping in
defense of the Queen side now it is
somewhat off here on g6 it it takes e4
that's a good thing but that's the only
thing that is doing this is some not
ideal however the whole situation is of
course not not fatal for black Bishop g4
now whites
Bishop can be activated and knight to e7
nothing else really and a for gaining
space queen c7 getting on the C file
yeah and it's difficult now to make any
any headway why just doing those little
things that help and age for this gain
space and now black only has a choice
between between two things and both are
not not really what you want you don't
want to get the bishop to 2h7 yeah so
playing let's say something like this
just just a-waitin move you get pushed
back to h7 and now this Bishop is having
a really hard time to get back into the
game it's really ridiculously posted
down you also really don't want to play
f6 as this is allowing the bishop to
come to e6 now in concrete completely
also night c 4 azov is a big problem
Jack yeah and then those kind of
discoveries are our problem at the
moment 96 there's quincy 1f for Jack
yeah but white can even afford to play
slow move and then take on d6 yeah well
you don't want to play of 6 it's just a
weakening of the of the e6 me6 square so
at the end Malaysian played h5 and this
is also not a move that you really want
to do because you put it on a light
square where the bishop is in a way
always yeah the piece that needs that
protects the pawn and is somewhat tied
to the spawn not the end of the world
but a little little concession a5 yeah
putting those on dark squares makes some
sense to UM here to make sure that with
be six then Bishop is not able to attack
the the pawns we have a funny situation
really if we look at
CM wear white is technically speaking
the the sorry the bad bishop on d3 but
he's got the thorns on light squares but
these terms don't really apply that much
the bad bishop and good bash bishop if
one side is having a huge advantage in
space and hear why it really has quite
substantial advantage in space with more
space it's not such a problem that
you're technically speaking have the bad
bishop because your bishop has enough
space within you are within your
position to maneuver and let's say
blacks bishop is technically the good
bishop but what it is actually doing on
g6 it's a yeah absolutely doing nothing
a taxi form but this will easily be
resolved later when white can play a
free for example the other thing that is
clearly happening in this position there
can be situations where black has
problems to defend the h5 pawn yeah note
something like this night to hear there
should be two and then it's gone on h5
attacking twice and hard to defend can I
get a knight to f6 but yeah this is just
an a feature of the position yeah is it
that white is clearly better I don't
think so black still is very solid but
it is some very difficult to defend such
a passive position and we have this
typical kind of gamer widest slowly
slowly probing and advancing one problem
for black really is if you look at the
night iam yeah you would absolutely love
to improve this this piece but where
where exactly um you would like to get
it to c5 but this is tough to do that's
not really a good route to do that and
also once you move it away there might
be night see for coming attacking b6 and
d6 and one of the pawns get lost black
has some problems with the with his
pieces but it's still it's not the end
of the world he defended well at first
g5 we are gaining some space maybe a for
later if if possible yeah why does
gaining the the most space that that
there is possible yeah and I think here
we have the crucial position of the game
up to now among vision has defended well
I think it's yeah it's not much fun and
everything but probably a white cannot
win if black is defending perfectly I
think here you needed to play night to
g6 this is some I think a necessary move
after f5 which is probably what white
will do I mean I don't think that night
jitu can can be enough after that he
gets just able to take everything off
and I don't think white has any winning
chances here you can attack the h5 pawn
but this is always easily defended black
can't even just put this here and how is
right going to get HM don't think so um
yeah white must play a 5 ok f5 here and
after that you go to add form and yeah
the night is now actively placed on air
for this is relatively speaking actively
if we look at Bishop f1 the night has no
square to go to but still it is not
evident how how wide is is making any
progress you know the night f4 is
protecting the h5 porn and if white
tries for a double attack off the pawn
like King f2b should be too black and
even consider to just take off the
bishop I really don't think that white
can win this I see no way at least the
big difference to the gamers and we
should really compare it directly to the
game he played Bishop to e8 after which
cards and played f5 yeah and here we
have the same structure but with the
night on e 7 and
7 the night has reduced the total
passivity cannot do anything and whites
a general plan yeah well is shown in the
game he attacked the pawn and now he
brought the king of one it is not
strictly necessary to do necessary to do
so but it is just the best technical way
to play he prevents b5 that there's no
kind of counter play and now the king is
going all the way to a3 before gaining
that most on the queenside and now when
the Queen's idea is totally am yeah I
taken care of right now can think about
the h5 pawn this is still the main
weakness and we see check right is
traveling all the way to g3 the thing I
mentioned a long time ago after h4 h5
this pawn can be a weakness and it is a
fawning right now black has no way to
defend it and this would have been a big
difference imagine just to try to
imagine this position with the night on
f4 instead on g8 then h5 is Sam is
secured yeah and now it is falling and
the rest is yeah like child's play form
for cars with this technique ya hear
black resigned because of a zoot swan
he's losing the beep horn or the f6 porn
and yeah after that there is no use in
trying to fight so good win for cards in
typical stars kind of dry position that
he excels in ok the next game is again
via the Magnus just just a moment yeah
it is loaded yeah I'm cutting out the
loading process because it gets this
incredibly note noises by the peace
movements may I have to load the game
sir one by one
find sm as you see where i'm doing this
s not does not have all the games easily
accessible here for the top tournaments
they mostly have it term and it's easily
accessible for them ok this is calzon
koala this is from round 10 actually
very decisive game where it was decided
if Carson's takes the lead or kawana
let's see interesting opening vodka
wanna it is quite apparent that if you
look at their opening some of the top
players and those rapid events they very
often play em they don't play the
absolute main openings but go for
something slightly offbeat not nothing
crazy but yeah an opening like that the
philly doors um this is perfectly okay
opening it's not one of those yet top
openings for black where you can play
for full equality and so on or try to
simplify or get a super-sharp position
it's just a position to get the game
going yeah like develop stuff and get
your pieces out the slide space
disadvantage but it's a playable
position yeah ed for is an interesting
interesting way to play I wasn't really
aware that this is the line but it seems
to be um normally they they castle here
and why just now playing wookie one nor
a for those kind of moves taking an
interesting decision I think one idea is
that after Knight takes there are ideas
nowadays to play quick night to be six
so attacking the bishop and well this is
not a great idea because of pubs not
this because of c-5 when your bishop on
b3 as getting into into slide travel so
the council took with the with the Queen
and again Knight b6 so oops slightly lay
here bishop retreat to be three castles
yeah we have a position that is quite
typical of this dis opening for black
like as a space disadvantage but is
fairly solid
it's um yeah it's it's a disadvantage
but it's um it's a manageable yeah five
sugar for a white white has good
development for sure we should 2g form
developing Queen D 397 this intends to
put the night on c5 and the bishop on f6
slowly trying to activate the pieces 94
and why puts this night on b5 that's a
fairly typical way to play in various
positions that have this e for porn
lower the 36 pawn this can happen in a
king's indian in an old Indian and other
lines where en deep on I exchange
sometimes also in the Budapest gambit
when you put the night on bhai if you
put pressure on the whole black Queen
side the night is always attacking c7
and 2d6 so that you cannot easily play
see six to expel it so you have to live
with this night on b5 for quite a quite
a while and sometimes even I d5 coming
and then you cannot expel it with c6 so
this is a fairly normal way to put
pressure on like nothing terrible or
anything but just a typical maneuver
yeah black have decided to get rid of
this bishop here on b3 gaining the
bishop pair but you won't keep it for
very long because what i said this 95
business is happening and yeah here the
pressure on c7 is getting so serious
that black must take it eb-5 and now I'm
koala played rook c8 yeah it looks
totally normal c7 was attacked and I
suppose he didn't play Knight c5 because
of this tactical shop tonight c7 which
it first looks really bad for black
but it is not that terrible Black has
very weird but satisfactory reply can
play Bishop to h4 yeah of course the
caption Bishop t6 is totally wrong but
it's quite remarkable with Bishop h4
this counter attack you make sure that
the pressure on the six is reduced and
after this you can even simply take here
and play this position which is job
maybe slightly better for white there
are some attacking chances on the Kings
side if you think about those kind of
ideas but this is better than the game
Black is some having a good position of
them i don't see five yeah it's a blitz
player rook c8 yeah and this is has a
slight problem with with cards and
immediately spots you place Bishop to
detune yeah and now the problem is a
five hangs and how do you protect this
pawn it's a not so easy you absolutely
cannot play move like v6 this is leading
to a terrible situation with the night
coming to see six black is totally boxed
in then don't want that in turn yeah
what what else is there you must play
Bishop b5 and this is what happened
there should be five queen age three
this is in fact debatable it's possible
that Queen f3 was veteran yeah the idea
being that the queen is having a look
let's say on c6 again this should be too
it's not really a problem you can play
Bishop Roxy to and something like this
is quite clearly favorable for wide yeah
if we consider such a position just for
argument's sake here black can only for
a while play a 95 and now before it's
the problem you cannot take this night
is going to get lost
it's going to get lost or you must play
very weird stuff like ooh gate and allow
the capture the Queen side is really
under some pressure Carlton move seems
to be a bit less powerful and played
queen age three and then fc6 was
possible it still looks slightly better
for white but it's not as convincing
maybe as putting the knight on f3 the
Queen on f3 we have this happening now
need technical shot on a five this was
what he has planned and jam talent the
seventh takes and takes and now the move
Queen d2 yeah it seems that this is
maybe not so precise but it's very it's
a very difficult thing to look at those
rapid games and check it with computers
and they will point out numerous
inaccurate moves it's simply simply a
human you cannot play if you have some
seconds per move you cannot play
perfectly that's that's clearly the case
it seems that instead of Queen B 2 there
was some Queen before which was a bit
more precise attacking be three yeah one
point is that after Queen B 7 there is
Jack this funny movie yeah but this do
these kind of things are very tough to
spot for a human of course jack yeah why
does not need to take and shouldn't take
probably but this is the point they
played Queen d2 and this has a drawback
which also was not played by Carlton
Queen c7 queen bee to Quincy to is
securing a very stable wide advantage
causal plate rook c1 and this is again a
very human thing to do because if you
calculate this year it's just totally
clear black is attacking I'm sorry about
this is a ticking be too twice and the
only thing that you really calculate
after you get one
east at least this will be my approach
I'm not consummate I would mostly look
at those captures I mean black ones is
porn back and it turns out that those
captures I indeed really a mistake what
we should be too can be easily handled
would take here it's clear that the
apron is is strong and even now d 5 is
not really good the bishop is misplaced
them he took with the Queen this
happened and Queen B seven and now the a
pawn is super strong I think this is
almost a decisive advantage now when we
to really am was it was a mistake but to
see that to see the right move is not
easy you shouldn't take on between all
you should play Queen to d5 covering
this and keeping both pawns he attacked
you know and here black has a much more
activity and then comparison one
important thing is for example if you
look at V for Quincy form it's a good
move if consider this ok this is full of
technical tricks and the the real reason
why queen d 5 is better are those are
those little tricks yeah so that white
here needs to lose a move due to this
threat this for example then you take
Quinn be seven and then you take a form
and you have equality it's a it's very
difficult to do this with a limited time
I don't have the the times that they
that they have left them don't have it
available so you cannot really say okay
he had the three minutes on the clock
should you see that I don't know very
true very tricky he took on b2 Queen B
seven queen bee three and a five and it
turns out this is pretty clearly shown
by by a Houdini or any other engine the
a porn is decisive now black helium has
no no defense he tried d5 Quincy six
yeah that's an important to mediate move
you can also start a six but rook b8
looks a bit and come
to go yeah it's playable you can play
rook see one but it makes it somewhat
more difficult this is easier first this
and now Roxy one playing with this
checkmate threat very often checkmates
Roxy ATM if black takes here for example
its whoopsie it made checkmate threads
are very very important tool in the in
the end game especially here with the
week back ranks blackest going for g6
securing some look for the king but it's
too late yeah the a porno is running
yeah black black cannot take on b5
really well it played Queen a2 we look
at this or yeah or the immediate a
sadness maybe even even more precise it
leads to the same end game check ya hear
white will also win the d5 pawn and this
end game is a relatively easy win white
um is coming all the way over to he ate
with the king and the text f7 from the
seventh-ranked with the rook this is the
the winning idea in this end game they
played Queen a too and after some
preparation here rook c8 is the next
idea getting rid of the defending rook
now eh queen is coming jack and like I'd
give a couple of checks pushing the King
all the way to h3 but the Queen on CH is
nicely protecting this diagonal there's
nothing happening Queen d3 and white
could promote Queen f1 check you simply
have Queen g2 and can block the check
yeah this was a decisive game of round
10 which brought counts on the the lead
in the tournament so on very crucial
game so who sir also at the top Letson
have a look at nakamura he had this bed
start losing against the hitter azhaga
in the first round but he his stage to
come back
won a couple of games he had only three
points after the first five rounds but
then he started to win some games and
among those can spoiling the result I'm
sorry he played played Milosevic always
interesting let me load this game ok
game is loaded moral playing eve form
and the sicilian with be three yeah this
is a funny line that has gained some
popularity in in in recent years why one
reason was that it was even played by a
viral chronic and chrome dick is always
a trendsetter in openings people very
much look at what chronic is doing and
yes study the stuff that he's playing
it's usually very well found at his his
opening choices ok be 396 Knight f6 very
logical black getting the nights out
yeah and we have this advanced and g6
yeah all this looks really normal I
think yeah both white theoretically
speaking can play a six-year opening the
diagonal but f6 is perfectly acceptable
for black jack this is with e5 coming
pretty nice for black so we developed
him with night Bishop c4 and he took on
c6 and castles yeah white has given up
the bishop power but he has established
a nice pawn on e5 that secures some
advantage in space and here so pretty
easy development rookie 1d 392 yeah
pretty easy development but come on
replace C for another like we like this
move that's a good decision I think not
playing a routine lose but pushing the
sea pawn this pawn move really asks
right okay how are you going to set up
your
do you want to really keep the pawn on d
2 don't you want to move it sometime and
if he moves it we can actually change
the sea porn for the deep on and this is
what what happened in the game he played
d3 and now we have exchanged our CC porn
for the deep on this is nice i think and
black wants to fight for the center with
d6 yeah also you must get your bishop
out now it is maybe possible even to
develop with tempo yeah see force plate
you are keeping this night at bay and
black took on e5 this is motivated of
course by the fact that black has two
bishops you want to open up as much as
possible and in the concrete situation
there are also some some technical
considerations yeah y TF with the Queen
hanging on d3 must exchange which puts
your rook on the D file and one point is
what is wide smooth now he took only
five and Bishop f5 what I meant with
technical considerations is the long
diagonal here mu flag 97 can easily be a
problem for white as yeah you're pinned
with the night on e5 this makes them
this position not so easy to play for
white it seems that the next move by
amorosa which already is a slight
mistake and if we look at the the engine
analysis it comes up with the move
Bishop to see three it's a bit weird
move but it has somewhat at some point
the bishop on c3 is actually protected
by the night on b1 and we may be are
able to just retreat the night let's say
something like this rook c8 and neither
three now we have chances to get this
bishop exchanged if we look at this for
example the position immediately shifts
in whites favor as the bishops are one
and now White has a slight advantage due
to black having
porn Islands those pawns I want somewhat
weak and wide width to pawn Island some
has a slightly more comfortable position
black probably does not want to exchange
he wants to remove the bishop and then
try to play with f65 but yet White has
gained this idea and maybe get the night
out later this seems to be quite okay
this bishops III idea trying to exchange
and he played f4 which looks very normal
but after 97 there is a slight problem
here what should we do now it's not so
easy to even make a move yeah you cannot
let say play Knight c3 yeah as black it
takes and directly invades here looks
very uncomfortable and really should be
avoided yeah night a three is what you
played an ID too yeah okay fails fails
completely losing a piece yeah and what
else is there a plate 9 a-3 as mentioned
and now nakamura took it Bishop takes
and now a very important moment very
important it sometimes can happen if you
see some some some less experienced
players playing that they that they
exchanged lots of pieces they want to
exchange stuff because they think it
gets let's say more manageable the
position is that it's easier to play but
very often the exchanges the wrong idea
Bishop f8 here is much much stronger you
need to preserve your bishop and you
haven't threat here like a threatening
f6 and e5 with an attack on the loose
night on a three-year the night on a
three look at this piece yeah wyd
certainly didn't want to do it but he
didn't really have much of a choice
after f4 he wasn't trouble the night on
a 3 has no square to go to look at the
bishop yeah why does in fact trying to
get rid of this piece but of course
black is playing just age 5 yeah
securing the great wish
591 you need to get this piece and to
play on a three it's it's really
terrible King f7 and e6 very important
getting the bishop back into play on be4
on c5 there are those two possibilities
that come into mind and note that black
also has invasion squares on the default
d2 and d3 very important a much much
more comfortable position for black
hammer yeah we're also good just trying
to defend but it's it's very tricky a5
is typically you want a 5a for trying to
exchange your pretty much useless a porn
on a4 possibly on b3 to take that so
that at the end b3 can in fact even
become a weakness so a typical device
this a 5 move and wide retreats to c3 to
stop a for rube d3 and 94 yeah this is
really showing how tricky it is to allow
a for white just wants to block this
black and some activating its pieces to
the utmost Bishop to d2 to f1 here must
cover for Andrew create yeah white is
under huge pressure very uncomfortable
position Bishop see one and of course we
treating not exchanging you only want to
get get one of the bishops exchange in
half in as a trade or for something
really really good yeah you want to pawn
two points in exchange whatever
something serious other than that you
will keep the bishops on the board and
keep the pressure on yeah look T 1 and
here in this very unattractive position
murasa which was face there was the
threat of rook f1 King f1 Bishop d3 so
let's say why play something I know it
does not make much sense i know there's
this this thing happening
losing an exchange this is the the
threat and you need to do something
again said of course here at the end he
played a bishop night would be to to to
cover that but there was a second second
threat and this is the one plate now
Jake's takes d3 is covered but the
bishop can also go to be one and attack
the spawn chain and it turns out that
this is not defensible something like
this for example if you just go here and
take everything off he played nine to a
four and now yeah the exchange is lost
he has not blundered this he was just
being faced with the decision giving up
the Queen side or giving up the exchange
so he gave up the exchange but um of
course now we enter a technical stage
that no cameras is doing quite quite
nicely we can say look at it and it
later this traded and the rookin Bates
Blackie didn't really have a big big a
choice than to give up the e porn but
you want to have you look activated and
it's very important in this end game
here black is is in control or totally
white cannot do anything much so what
you need to do is keep patient don't
rush and slowly try to accumulate your
advantages there is no big bonus for
winning quickly the thing is to to win
it all and do it safely and the cameras
just probing here and there trying to
improve it's not like he's making very
obvious progress but yet slowly gaining
space on the Queen on the Kings side
with g5 ok and now g flag check this
means that the night cannot go to f3 the
night is limited
go to a three it cannot go to e4 as the
king is controlling this and the night
does since no real square on the first
rank so he also must watch out for the
porn on b3 and now black has a winning
idea and this is of course cutting the
King on the third rank and entering with
your own king after this here murasa
which resigned yeah there's absolutely
no defense here you in some sort of a
Zook swung the night cannot move without
giving up the pawn and if you move the
king let's say here you have the choice
you can can enter here or you can also
switch over to win the g2 porn it's also
good so very nice performance by
nakamura he had won this game fairly
convincingly of course also one or two
shaky games against when velia I think
it was pretty much lost but one anyway
in inverted complications and yeah my
camera's fate really decided in a way
and also in round 10 when he faced the
most successful player end of the second
half and this is 11 Aronian that me load
the game game loaded yeah this was
erroneous Kimura they were both very
close to the top so it was this game to
decide um what what happens next and
nakamura explained the Queens gambit
accepted again this seems to be an
opening that he has prepared for this
event with some offbeat lines one of bid
line was efore b5 that he had to play
before against the Potkin this is better
than it looks a b5 it looks a bit
strange in lots of introductory books on
the Queens gambit it is said that you
cannot do this at all this b5 business
but there are cases where you can do it
it leads to murky plane
after Knight f3 by the way there are
also ideas like that with a 6b five or
sometimes they're also ideas where black
is trying to keep the porn with Bishop
e6 not immediately but some something
like that it looks totally strange but
this is really an opening line that has
some merit um Aronian plays III and i
think one reason is that this is the
most straightforward way to get the porn
back here b5 really it's not a good idea
after you form as you don't even have
seasick this is st. not that this is the
well-known kindergarten trick to win the
rook so you cannot really do something
like that and like mrs play a 5 this is
really the choice to play if you want to
yeah keep it independent from the Queens
gambit accepted main lines black of
course can just play this and play the
absolute main line but this is probably
not what nakamura had prepared you
wanted some independent lines so we went
a five not a bad choice de5 is is really
check just comfortable for black he will
get the high upon back so Bishop c4 is
played take stakes now we have a very
typical isolated Queen composition but
an isolated Queen prone position that is
some not happening that often with e
file open very often you have it with
the pawn on e seven or then coming to e6
here the e-file is open and this
diagonal is open for pressure on f7 so
this is a slightly different affair than
many other isolated queen porn positions
all right Abby should be six another 39
f6 and now this is a very crucial point
right here has some two basic choices he
can play castles and play a typical full
let's say middle game with Queens on the
board and everything or I can play the
somewhat
newer move between to eat to check and
this is what aronian Aronian did I
really like this move I must admit if we
look at what happens I think this is a
very good choice this check is slightly
uncomfortable for black you can retreat
the bishop but then why it has gained
something with the Queen on e to having
one sort of the tempo castles coming
rookie one looks a slightly better maybe
rook to d1 yeah Queenie to is okay in
this position yeah black might be able
to play castles Andrew create to put it
poster the queen but then you just go to
situ and still have gained something
with the bishop being back on e seven
yeah nakamura played Queenie seven this
is also the the move that's normally
recommended and now the Queen trade yeah
and here after the Queen trade black
yeah has a choice can place can play
Bishop e7 or can take with the King
taken with the kin looks uncomfortable
moving the king or leave so it took with
the bishop and now why just continues to
develop there is this idea black needs
to probably cover that and he did this
with a six rookie one and here we come
to an interesting point already to be
honest I really like white already I
don't I don't really um think I i would
like to play black IAM like I'm were up
late bishop to the eighth with which
does not look very active but should be
six looks yeah more normal but if you
consider something like this this has
been played before Bishop to g5 9bd
seven and 95 yeah this just looks like
white is somewhat better he's got all
the activity Scott pressure on f7 I
would very much prefer to be white him
it's probably not the end of the world
but
I don't know white fields more
comfortable played Bishop to d8 and now
Bishop f4 simple but strong developing
the bishop and always looking at this
pawn and you cannot easily move it want
to move the porn okay I'm going to win
you look here on fh when they exchange
very embarrassing moment so c6 is not
possible and this means you always have
to for the moment god this is a c7 porn
with the piece this will be the bishop
on the eighth and yeah do you want to
keep it on da de all the time yeah
Nakamura is trying to get his pieces
developed Luke see one on the half-open
see file Knight b6 and be sure to be
three Karen age six tough to give black
some advice he probably wanted to
prevent something coming to g5 getting
some look for the king but it's
difficult to do something active really
d5 yeah typical advanced making sure
that c6 is never never never ever going
to happen and yeah it also frees space
for night to deform maybe yeah it helps
in this Bishop a bit but the pawn on d5
is just huge accomplishment we should
five trying to get it out and h3 a
little improving move but also with
aggressive intentions so white is not
just playing age 34 nothing he wants to
gain space on all sides of the board g4
has the first step chinese I know 95
yeah just a great position for white be
sure to e8 h 4
yeah very tough to play this position
what should like do now yeah become well
played night f.2d 7 I don't think this
is really great but it's a it's tough to
play the system of this position really
tough the computer wants to play
something like Bishop e7 which looks
very unhuman putting this Bishop right
into this efile a move like 97 looks
very nice at first and it is nice for
Wyatt as I'm not saying it isn't but
check this here might be might be a
still a defensible position like has two
bishops the initiative White has two
bishops and the initiative more space
but maybe something like this is is
something you can hold not much fun but
can can try they played this and here I
think aronian even could have played
better than what he did he took on d 7
which preserves a clear advantage but it
seems that instead 93 was even better
and I'm a bit surprised that he didn't
play it because it's a fairly logical
thing not to exchange pieces when black
is so boxed in and it also has the
technical justification it just the
texts this bishop here and how do you
protect the bishop you go Knight f6 sg5
and you loose material you actually only
have yeah you can take here if you want
but then Bishop c7 looks fantastic now
with the deep the dr the deep on being a
passer not be 526 coming fantastic
position or you can play king here then
i go g5 and here you're almost super
smart like her so it's no no square
hotel he can play I know look CA to a 8
or something this is probably even
stronger than what he played he took and
play g5 comparable but it's probably not
as convincing it is however a very very
difficult position for like
why does now slowly pushing d6 the next
step yeah if black would take now check
you would have yeah this is what your
what your face check check just one way
of losing the game quickly yeah c5 was
necessary and now check why does
shifting is is played even over to this
threatening checkmate and it's really a
sorry state the only thing that black
can do here to to do to try to defend
this is what he played he played king to
g8 yeah you also cannot do this check
check and white white is winning as well
just hear the check goes back and Bishop
b3 this is what he needed to allow
threatening rookie Jade mate and
detecting c4 so black is just losing
this pawn he had no alternative really
the idea was to now go here and this has
happened this has happened in the game
attacking f4 and detecting g5 so why
does some as he wants to keep the
material and not forced but he took him
didn't want to go King g3 this was was a
also sensible option something like this
is also a very nice position for wine
but ok this is ok took it and played
King g3 why does keeping his extra porn
he's got d6 as a passer and it is still
very very uncomfortable to play um here
whatever I think like I will I had a
better defense he could have played King
to f7 and this has won a very important
difference to the game if now Bishop e3
black can take
and after this we'll be able to approach
with the king that's that's a very
important important resource in the game
he played this and now this Bishop b3
was a yeah far bigger problem as after
the trade this didn't happen but after
the trade right now does not have any
problems with the deep on here we'll
just play a 4 and possibly try to
regroup the knight to e5 just one
possibility or luke a 5 white is in
total control he retreated and now why
doesn't answering his Bishop to g5 this
is covering everything ff4 46 pawn and
whitis in clear control and now it's
going over to the to the Queen side with
the King Jack trying to decide the game
there yeah just white has time there's
no need to rush things yeah tough
decision but he tries to get two
opposite colored bishops but it's very
very difficult to give them give black
some advice here it does not seem to to
to be enough for for a good defense but
what to do here even this which looks a
bit counterintuitive trading routes to
opposite colored bishops even this year
is the total win for white it's a just
too much with the White King invading
one problem is that if black goes a form
why does some not taking but place
before the e5 bishop is always
controlling the a pond and here why it
is just go into our King a6 going to
promote the pawn
he gave it up directly but there is no
no defense whatsoever Jack yeah and here
the final stroke is b7 it's quite nice
after that Nakamura resigned have to
take it king here now d 7 is threatening
actually made in a couple of moves so
the only thing to avoid the mages this
and this is only delaying things for a
while why this of course easily winning
so Nakamura lost this game in round 10
meaning that he is somewhat behind now
cards and leads with 8 points out of 10
and he's followed by aronia was seven
and a half points so this was a very
crucial gone in round 11 we see the game
aronian cards which will be a very very
important of course for the final
standings there is a huge number of
players with seven points kiwanis vigil
agree shook are not Tomashevsky a couple
of players they also still have chances
but what they would need to do is
probably to beat Carlton or let's say
beat the winner of Aronian Carson in the
last couple of rounds lots of the the
top top matchups are already have
already been played so there will be
some pairings where where Carson Aronian
the top guys we get slightly weaker
weaker relatively weaker opposition so
just the normal to town 2700 player so
it will be very important not to stumble
against those guys also are not on seven
points he's a fantastic rapid player you
never know you never know what's going
to happen if Arnold is playing cousin
this is a very very cautious a very
crucial match up of course and my going
to happen never know okay i hope you
liked it I'll do find a wrap up of the
last five Ron certainty featuring
Aronian Carlton yeah thanks for watching
I'll be back tomorrow bye